this is definitely not our first view I
have seen this movie quite a bit of
x-men um what do you think of this movie
when it came out originally I liked it I
liked it yeah no that's where I am NOT
I'm still there and I like it
love it its biggest accomplishment is
that it showed that an x-men movie can
be done okay like and everybody was
something I hate hate the production
design I think it is a bland looking
movie what would you prefer yellow
spandex yes shouts that in the movie I
literally I remembers in the screening I
just went yes somebody left behind me
and they went in first class Sam here I
thought it was okay I liked it more when
it came out because again it's finally
an x-men movie like I loved x-men
reading it so just to get anything even
close to good I was happy with but even
I knew okay this isn't really x-men why
Olivia want are attached to it yeah I
haven't seen this movie in years though
I'm curious to see especially now
compared to comic book movies being for
the most part pretty faithful to the
original source I'm curious to see how
it holds up so let's take a look this is
our purview in a while of x-men what's
the X what's the X what's the Act what
yeah even these credits okay I know I
remember I remember with the opening
credits I was just like what the hell do
you even say there is except even again
first class did it better yeah it is
hard to do commentary on this part if
you want really good commentary watch
the rip tracks on this it's trying to be
about something I
I don't dislike this see no I I think
it's that you done pretty well honestly
though the problem now is we all know
this is Magneto's backstory but like
with Batman's parents they can die
whenever world war two it's a very
distinct time so it's like you're gonna
get to a point where it's like magneto
should be dead every time they show that
backstory and they he's a mute he's a
mutant that's also his mutant powers you
can live forever it's a cool breeze
however it fails to address the issue
that is the focus of this hearing are
mutants dangerous wait wait wait I don't
get this they're discussing this
separation but there's not a national
emergency
I know standing with an international
emergency line
because I was whispering before now I'm
shouting fun trivia that truck driver is
the voice of beast this is lawful city
oh my god yeah just that one line I'm
like yeah my god how is that gonna look
so fake and x-men origins tosses a
quarter to the bartender after killing
greed oh sorry I'm sorry that's a mess
that's okay I sleep another ten miles
Shing if she can't touch anyone all she
needs to do is move to Japan to become a
hickie mori live in one room never come
out sit there watch anime all night you
know for the master of magnetism he kind
of those boring stuff with you know
something else that they said they said
this movie was really cut down and now
them watching it again I'm like yeah
these shots are not given time to
breathe at all
like that shot of him coming in focus
like that was so quick and it is this a
sped up what and it's like they don't
allow it to give time which kind of
sucks actually to this movies credit
this is my biggest nightmare I wake up
and I'm back in school
yeah this were totally flying to school
now a half-naked man runs in well a
bunch of kids oh my god oh she looks
terrible she do you like my wake I'm
cosplaying a storm today oh she looks so
good this is Cyclops he was on January's
issue of douche monthly over a when when
we're in California where'd you did see
many parts of the
my mansion oh nice it turns out they
shot pretty much any movie ever that has
a mansion is shot at this place like Big
Lebowski spider-man Jubilee Kitty and
rogue are all the same age all right so
you sr-71 fighter jet here and
everything so basically this is like
Hogwarts you're going to protect kids by
making yourselves an obvious target and
going to war right yeah no people like
you or the reason I was afraid to go to
school as a child you know this makes me
think back to my childhood growing up
with Xavier
that's cannon I guess little weird in
context now he is uncharted regenerative
capability
uncharted but it's on the chart right
there you're literally looking at charts
of his abilities I don't know her whole
performance is just she's fucking dying
let me tell us where you fucking good
for duck it has that face like
throughout the whole movie I'll just say
it too they turn him into a stupid
mutant alright what a dumb jellyfish
want to see something really cool and
I'm just like okay I feel like he should
only speak in Tim Allen groans I really
wanted to pick even like the Wardrobe
like oh she's got a green hood okay I
know she wore green but what she's got
like this long scarf and like just
regular jeans go ahead make it yellow
brown jacket or something you give her
the whites trees this bland ass early
2000s wardrobe that's the other thing
it's like that the wardrobes bland the
production designs bland the special
effects are bland
everything about this is bland and while
I appreciated the movie back then even
then I said it was a little on the bland
side and you would have thought I was
the Antichrist talking to some of my
friends like oh it takes a degree of
control and uh for someone like me it's
dangerous I can mansplain myself thank
you
these movies even boring your cat it's
been asleep for the past 20 minutes oh
he's my kitty pryde
now I know what you're thinking I must
look ridiculous yep old wine what young
people think old people say actually
this whole scene I think is awesome and
that is just like the creativity I'm
just like oh shit can't you read my mind
and find someone who looks at you the
way mystique looks at magneto as the
easiest thing I've ever heard his helmet
somehow designed to block my telepathy
what I'm like wrymouthale doing monsters
ball
what the hell am I doing here this whole
section here I remember being the most
boring and it does feel like it goes the
slowest it's showing us things that we
saw yeah there's always the part where
I'm like okay now I'm feeling bored and
it is a part yeah it's like we know all
this there's no new character so why are
we seeing it again it doesn't look good
is somebody there somebody tell me that
I look pretty good there god it's me
punchy white doughy guy did he just take
a shit
I'm still in this oh we do Jess oh you
you know it's the battle we've always
wanted to see all the x-men vs. toad yes
alright finally what is it uh I can only
control the weather I don't know what to
do it's like his only strategy that
seems to be working is just confuse them
to death by how goofy he is you know
what happens to a toad when it's struck
by lightning the same thing that happens
to everything else that was the ultimate
insult then he dies on that ultimate
insult that's a terrible in spices let's
point those claws of yours in a safer
direction so exciting you my nipples are
kind of deposits I've seen senator Kelly
he's dead
you sure you saw what you saw hello that
argument is like yeah
fabulous I did love their line of
yourself so self-righteous you'd be up
there that is the Internet and Wow yeah
this is amazing it should be awesome and
Hitchcock did this better in North by
Northwest and Mount Rushmore and that
movie came out we'll even he had a fight
does a statue of liberty it was better
than this oh yeah that's right
smoosh ooh well that looks amazing
I'll give the movie this much crane the
effect terrible the shot I have she
thought it was really cool I'm like I
love that idea I just wish that effect
they could have pulled it off yeah it's
a cool idea
well I okay this is the first because I
I last time I saw this it was on VHS
this actually looks worse on DVD yeah
more I can see that the worse it looks
bleached out and ugly oh god that looks
awful
that's the most stock reaction crowd
I've ever heard have a shot I'm taking
it taking the west-world audition yep
they're really gonna kill rogue all the
x-men died like three times in these
movies at this point it's like yeah the
time hopefully won in some respects the
x-men movies really have become the
x-men comics good just everybody dies
everybody keeps coming back and it kind
of means nothing same after I saw van
Helsing that's the best effect
in my opinion that really looks like it
he'll II just see the blood and on the
the cloth there and then it's got I'm
like that's totally convincing it's so
simple it's so easy
I think she's you can tell her my heart
belongs to someone else
I love they tried to build this up but
you know in the future the best romance
he's gonna have is between him and
Xavier so we think about it that was a
bromance for the ages okay so we are at
that gate if you look that you're not
gonna be Elsie here was actually two
hours on it uh-huh and that was only put
there because of Richie Rich and they
never took it today never took it so
people I love the are stayin forth
Richie Rich
just finish the x-men cartoon team
you're halfway there yeah you're right
you just give it the time I'm not gonna
like coming out of it says directed by
Bryan Singer I'm like yep that really
felt like it is a lot more underwhelming
okay now coming out of it I don't know
because we've been ripping in a new one
the whole time but I don't hate it
oh I didn't I didn't sit here and go
that was a complete waste of my time I
was miserable every second nothing got
better no nothing just better enjoyed it
just well enough the one thing that does
get better as they go on is each x-men
movie even like the worst ones there is
something you go whoa or Wow - there's
not one where it's like well there was
nothing interesting it's like there is
something it's like well that was cooler
that was really neat or something and
this one just really does not even yeah
I don't know I've always thought Bryan
Singer is incredibly afraid he had like
one great movie usual suspects and it's
been this kind of steady slide since
then or just wildly inconsistent and the
x-men films suffered for it it
definitely did not give better watching
it years later but it's it's still that
same level of okay on that lazy note I
also end on a lazy note you owe me a
scream
you